we've been uh uh i know a lot of people
it's a meme tim poole talking about
civil war
but with the uh the election coming up i
i wanna i wanted to ask you specifically
about this because you're canadian
what's your perspective on what's
happening here do you like so
the escalation of violence right so
recently we've had a bunch of trump
rallies
and then the left shows up and starts
attacking the trump supporters
and now you've got these stories popping
up in mainstream news that
right-wing militias are coming and
they're going to take over and it's like
they're not even anywhere in sight like
who are these people but i'm curious
based on your perspective
as canadian what you think's going to
happen well i mean the thing with
american politics is that
it's it's kind of it's kind of like an
std it spreads yes
what starts in american politics is
going to infect the rest of the country
and i use the word infect very
consciously
look at things like critical race theory
right that's everywhere started off in
academia i think
kind of like well i mean there's
argument to me to be made like the
frankfurt school german and stuff but i
think you know a lot of it
has come from americans and now it's all
over the western world and i mean we see
the same thing with like let's take
black lives matter
there are black lives matter protests in
montreal in toronto we've seen them in
europe so
it's everywhere um and you know with
these antifa groups they're getting
bolder in the us
again we're seeing that in places like
montreal like toronto um
so you know when we see this escalation
happening in the united states it's only
a matter of time before it kind of
spreads especially in canada we're so
close
and culturally like very very similar
especially with social media
so it's kind of scary to see um because
even in canada our last election cycle
canadians are pretty apathetic about
politics you know for for better or
worse
you know because it's nice we don't
really ride as much but it's also
concerning because there are a lot of
problems that people don't talk about
um but yeah this past election cycle was
the first time it actually kind of felt
almost like an american one like pinot
people
were they were like well the hamilton
event i don't know if you saw with uh
dave rubin and max and bernier there
were antiques
that happened in canada um so i think
especially with the whole
barrett situation coming up things are
just going to get worse there's going to
be more and more attention right
tony barrett yeah this right um
regardless of what happens if they don't
manage to get her through before the
election then the democrats are going to
be galvanized and if they do manage to
get her through
then democrats are going to think that
uh handmaid's tale
i i read once that there was like a
ruling from a high court in canada that
saying sorry was not an admission of
guilt
i don't know if that's true or true i'm
not sure i haven't heard i wouldn't be
surprised though
right because that's like the the meme
about canada it's like
you know it actually counts it's kind of
disappointing because i mean on the
surface level
we're pretty free and don't get me wrong
i would if you're a canadian you're
still
very very lucky but the thing you have
to understand about canada is that right
to self-defense
not a thing right to bear arms not a
thing even your right to freedom of
speech
not really a thing we have this thing
called the canadian like charter rights
and freedoms but every essential right
and freedom
kind of has a little asterisk next to it
saying
subject to the whims of the government
right yeah right so part of the british
commonwealth yeah and
a lot of the law is kind of based on
like is it is it still though i thought
i thought they left
well no our our head of state is still
technically the queen she's still on
all of our money yeah that's weird and
she she appoints someone to
to run you guys vote for trudeau right
yeah
for whoever we have the parliamentary
system which i think is
inferior because the the administrative
head is
is also the legislative head and you
don't actually vote for a prime minister
you vote for
the party and whoever gets whatever
party gets the most votes the head of
that party becomes the prime minister
so for example if i'm an american i can
completely and i'm able to
in my own local district vote for let's
say a democrat but then for president i
want trump
and i want them to be able to have that
check and balance system between the
the parties you can't do that in canada
oh wow yeah
and now you're stuck with trudeau i feel
bad for you guys prime minister
blackface but he's dreaming
oh yeah he's pretty much and actually we
were talking about all the
economic hardships that corona is
causing he recently pledged to donate
400 million
canadian dollars to invite covet abroad
oh but that's like 10 bucks
okay yeah that's fair yeah this this
happening as
so many canadians on so many canadian
businesses are facing bankruptcies and
you know we're having a lot of economic
problems but it's okay because he's
taking care of
the world is he like is his hand held by
the queen how does that work how much
autonomy does he have oh he has total
attack
i mean it's largely ceremonial i mean
don't get me wrong if i
were somehow crowned monarch of england
i would like reform the commonwealth i
would get things going again
she controlled the military she controls
the military of australia i'm pretty
sure
i'm not sure about australia but i know
for canada it's it's largely ceremonial
i mean like on the books she is
technically but it's it's yeah like
people wouldn't go for it i was talking
to some british people too and i asked
them like what would happen if the queen
actually intervened in affairs and
they're like people would probably snap
and then flip out like it's it's it's a
she's you know she's a head of state
she does have the power but she never
uses it it's largely viewed as like
never going to happen yeah so she's
essentially like a figurehead and a
tourist attraction at this point
you know yeah you know the problem is
with all of our leaders
no well not trump not trump um trudeau
and the democrats
they're not leaders they don't want to
take responsibility for anything that
happens
so they're playing it perfectly if the
businesses get wiped out they can say
oh but but kovid you know we had locked
down if they release the lockdown
someone dies
they'll get blamed so that's the best
thing they can do is just say
well we had to lock down as a pandemic
and then as everyone's lives are
destroyed and businesses are wiped out
they can say oh don't look at me
it was coded yeah yeah but then if
people die they'll say why didn't you do
this why didn't you do that so they're
basically
use the heaviest hand possible to
absolve myself of any and all leadership
and responsibility
and then you get someone like trump who
of course is far from perfect but he's
saying like we got to keep the economy
going
and you had all of these these stories
coming out you had the u.n i guess
saying a study
250 million people could die from
starvation because the economy grinding
to a halt
and this is why doctors should not
choose how
like doctors don't run countries yes so
like you have fouchy saying all these
great things you know early on donald
trump's doing a great job okay that's
wonderful
then later on he's like well here's what
we should have done there are reasons
why
we elect people to represent us to make
decisions and we don't just have
appointed doctors because the doctor
doesn't understand how banking works
doctor doesn't understand how business
in new york works right the doctor's
going to be like this virus will kill
these people
we got to shut down to stop these people
from dying then the economists are going
to say
that's interesting we're going to lose
twice as many people if the economy
shuts down
right because starvation homelessness
sickness depression
suicide oh yeah all that stuff and it's
all just
the the the only thing we end up hearing
is and i love this part where they're
like you must listen to the science and
listen to the doctors it's like
okay all right then trump's doctors come
come out and they're like he's okay to
leave everything's great they're like no
he's sick he's gonna kill people there's
actually somebody tweeted
you know trump is going to kill people
by leaving and i'm like you know what
man
there is a tweet for every circumstance
about trump and whatever
and it's like they have done everything
their power to make sure he cannot
actually do anything
but they're not doing anything so you
know it reminds me of it reminds me of
like a dad like you know walking to the
backyard to like
i don't know fire up the grill and the
kids are holding on his legs screaming
and he's like trying to walk and the
kids won't let go
you're really annoying that's basically
what's going on in my opinion
um who do you think are some great
leaders in the world
man i don't know
that's a tough one if you had to pick
three like define leader i guess well
you define it
oh man good leaders not followers
i don't know what do you think you're
the guest well i mean there are certain
politicians that i like but um
like unfortunately for me they don't
always tend to win so i don't know i
don't know if you can call them leaders
rand paul yeah yes yeah definitely rand
paul rand paul i like
uh maxim bernier who's canadian he he
tried to start up the uh
the only actual like libertarian kind of
center-right party
in canada because the conservatives in
canada are like i mean they're
essentially democrats yeah i mean it's
still canada
um him i like let's see a third one
let's see anyone in europe that's cool
actor yeah victor orban he's kind of
authoritarian though but i i like a lot
of
a lot of what he does like i don't know
enough about him to say i support him
because
you know i'm sure there's probably
things that i don't
condone but i mean overall i think you
know when it comes to things like
immigration they've at least
been listening to their their people
which is something that a lot of people
i think in canada and the us don't feel
like it's happening
i guess i guess the question is like
what like a good leader is an opinion
right there's reasons to say why the the
democrats that are obstructing trump in
a million ways
you could argue is a good thing i
personally don't think so but i'm sure
they could come up with something like
oh but you know putting a check on
executive authority is important no
matter what and i'm kind of like
yeah but you know jamming a wrench in
the spokes for the sake of damaging the
spokes isn't it yeah you know real
leadership but i'm sure someone
could argue something like that you
could argue that vladimir putin is very
strong and he makes russia
yeah he's efficient right an efficient
leader yeah xi jinping
yeah also efficient hey look look china
is
is is dominating yeah and so sure
they've got concentration camps
the the question is like what
constitutes a good leader from an
american perspective
it's very very different from what other
people in the world would say for sure i
think i don't think those people are
good leaders by the way i think into
like the private sector
like elon musk definitely as a leader
jeff bezos is a leader
people a lot of might get down on me for
for saying that about jeff but i mean
he's got blue
what's that blue what's his space
program called you know i've been
spending a lot of time on facebook and i
just really like mark zuckerberg
we must all vote zuckerberg do you find
great leaders in the private sector do
you think they gravitate towards
politics or maybe
because i don't know sometimes i think
leaders can lead from behind sometimes
they can absolutely be in the private
sector and i think a lot of a lot of
them are in the private sector you know
who's a bad leader
jay inslee oh good oh yeah you know who
he is no
he's governor of uh washington and
boeing just announced they're leaving
so there's a lot of reasons yeah they're
losing a ton of money because no one's
flying anymore
so that means they're in trouble they
make planes i mean they make other
things too but yeah they do
uh so anyway they're going to
consolidate their production i think in
south carolina
and so now they're losing all these jobs
in washington but i do think it's a lot
to do with coveted restrictions
probably has a lot to do with the
rioting but we also have the same thing
with elon musk
he's moving i guess he's moving to texas
so man i'm seeing all this stuff go down
i remember when elon was like i'm
leaving because the state is
insane and they were basically harassing
him even though the state said here's
what you got to do to open and he was
like we're good
the local county was like no we're not
going to let you elon
so he leaves and just reminds me of
atlas drugged
all the all the heads of industry are
like we're out there you can have your
regulations there's this huge
exodus out of california right i mean
joe rogan's leaving elon musk is leaving
daley wire folks i mean blair white yeah
i feel like there's so many people who
are just like all right
i'm out and i don't i mean i don't blame
them and it's it's sad because there are
parts of california that are really
beautiful there are a lot of wonderful
people like there are good things about
california it's it's a very successful
state
in a lot of different metrics they
attract talent but
man do they love killing business there
they just they love i left in 2018
and i went back a few months ago and i
have no
at all desire to go back there it was
like so stuffy
and i mean it's this beautiful wide open
los angeles particularly wide open space
with
homeless people everywhere but this time
it was like you had to wear a mask and
everybody was like
i don't know well but the mask was
waiting in lines to get the groceries
but even
the mask is cause of the typhoid
outbreak not because yeah not a corona
but i went to i did my freshman year at
usc
and you know i grew up in southeast asia
but
la was the only time in my life that i
remember feeling genuinely unsafe for my
like just my personhood my property
i had i'd never experienced anything
it's like a horrible place it is
yeah it's a what it's a wretched hive of
scum love it
love it in like 2005 and six you know
weed was legal for the first time in my
life and i was like wow this is like the
liberal this is where we can change the
country
we can start here and it felt like that
and the entertainment industry was
killing it all these youtubers were
flocking to los angeles the beach
72 degrees every day and now they're
repealing civil rights law
the funny thing is about the the patrol
in san francisco is that it's actually a
problem in other cities too but
they're just the worst what i love about
san francisco is that this someone made
a map
of all of the instances of human poop in
the streets
and when you look at it there's so many
it's just a giant brown splotch
over the map you can't even see the city
yeah because there's
so many they actually had to hire a poop
patrol like it's like
could you imagine it's like your town is
going over their expenses like well the
fire department costs us this much
per year we have ems and police and ah
yes the poop department
like that's crazy is it taxpayer funded
yeah it's public it's a public program
it's like it's like
they come out with and spray the poop
down yeah that's that's nuts
like are there other departments we
don't know about that just don't
like register with us like we all know
the fire department we all know the
police department
but is there like other government
programs because the poop department
seems like
that's a new one yeah for sure you know
and and
and uh hopefully not the rest of our
future yeah well actually
we did a video about san francisco um we
called it san francis
but yeah they have their they have a lot
of infrastructure dedicated to the
homeless i think they spend like
an actual person's yearly income per
year on each homeless person because
what they're still homeless
um and it's it's crazy because and it's
actually i
i know a lot of conservatives like like
to laugh at san francisco
because they feel like this vindication
that ah all of your far left policies
are bad
but it is sad i remember i when i was i
think 18 or 19 i visited san francisco
and i thought it was beautiful
and it's like if you're from there and
you see what your city has become like
if you're a business owner out there
and now you have like someone shooting
up in front of your business every day
fees on the street there's like videos
online that have gone viral of like
women being attacked by random crazy
homeless people like that's
man i don't think and there's stuff and
and all the while there's a starbucks
literally across the street from the
starbucks
like no joke yeah yeah and there's like
i remember i was at a starbucks and this
is like
i forgot what this was like it's near
market street or something and i'm
walking out look around as i'm walking
out i'm like there's a starbucks across
the street there's a line
i was like but i just walked out of a
starbucks no line why would anybody
this is the weirdest yeah no no no
kidding that's starbucks is the good
starbucks
yeah yeah right in san francisco in
2014-ish i lived there for like a year
and it was really cool to get offered
like hey do you want to buy mushrooms as
you're walking down the street
the first time but like the 19th time
it's just
and then the guy's like trying to step
past step over people and pass people
and you're like no
man now you got like whole markets where
they're like just holding up in their
jackets they really will they'll
try and sell you like right up they'll
just walk up to you and be like want to
buy some mushrooms i don't know if they
do it to everybody
san francisco is you just have that's my
long hair
it's capital it's capital city from the
hunger games right yeah san francisco
yeah so you have these big
wealthy industries you have these these
tech companies that are in not
necessarily san francisco but the bay
area
super wealthy powerful big tech in
silicon valley
and then you have like it's it's like it
it's
the scariest thing about it is it
reminds me kind of of ukraine
where you have oligarchs who control
everything like you know
and then you have all extreme poverty so
think about
another city that would be like san
francisco and it's it's hard to find
where you have some of the wealthiest
people on the planet billionaires
running their empires most exams go and
at the same time
you have poor people taking dumps in the
street and doing drugs
and there's a rapid homelessness i think
india has a lot of cities not maybe not
a lot but delhi i think is like that
no for sure for sure i mean in the u.s
this is like a thicker one
it's it's it reminds me of ukraine where
a small handful of oligarchs control
everything
and because they're so wealthy they
basically set the prices and they'll
never
lose their power and that's kind of what
we get with big tech where they control
what we can see
hear and even say then you have all
these really
you know poor people so they're clearly
not interested in helping you know
anybody
well actually i think they they think
they're interested in helping people and
that's why they push
far left policies and i really do think
that a lot of the the people from san
francisco even somewhere like la that
has a huge you know
wealth and equality issue i think they
think the rest of the country is like
that like
in their cities you have the
millionaires the billionaires and the
homeless
people and i think they think a that's
common and b
it's also capitalism's fault so that's
why in these hubs of these liberal hubs
you have like
i mean literal socialists who want to
tear down the system so
this we were talking a little bit about
this before the show started but uh i
wanted to ask you because i i was sort
of asking you earlier but we'll just go
back into it
from a canadian perspective what do you
think is going to happen in the us on
election night
i mean i don't like usually to make
predictions because i'm always worried
about being put into one of those
like reels of people being wrong and
then owned so i tried i try to avoid
making any
any predictions but i i do think trump
will win i mean i definitely think he
was on course to win in a landslide
before the whole covet thing
um you know then things kind of became a
little bit unclear but
right now i think a lot of people are
tired of the restrictions and
a lot of people are worried about the
economy and i think trump has a proven
track record on that and i know a lot of
you know democrats are trying to say
that this torpedoed economy is trump's
fault but people remember right they
remember
like filing their taxes from last year
they remember how how
well things were going and i think they
trust that a lot more than biden but the
polls have
in some states biden's up like nearly
double digits yeah i mean i
remember what the poll said last time as
well and it's hard because i don't want
to be one of those people who just
dismisses
polls because they don't like what i
what i think and i want to just have
confirmation bias but i think there
there is a proven issue with trying to
pull trump supporters
and his base i think we saw that last
year and i know the last election cycle
two years ago
you know things didn't go well for the
republicans in terms of the house but
trump wasn't on the ticket then
right he is now and there are a lot of
people who probably didn't vote in the
primaries because trump wasn't there
they're maybe not necessarily
republicans
maybe not necessarily even politically
active but now that trump
is on the ticket this time i think it's
going to make a difference so
so the polls in 2016 were off by a
couple points
maybe like a point or two and so what
ended up happening is you had all these
forecasters like oh if michigan's going
hillary then trump's gonna win
trump ended up winning uh from uh due to
77 000 votes across several swing states
like in some states it was thin
margins where he got winner take all
electoral votes so he did really well in
the electoral college
the weird thing now is like uh we we had
a jack murphy on the podcast recently
and he asked me he's like do you think
the conditions that led to donald trump
are worse or do you think things have
gotten better i'm like oh it's way worse
and he's like so then why would trump
lose
and i'm like but the polls right the
polls were wrong come on like biden's up
by like
10 points in some of these polls like 14
27 among seniors like some ridiculous
numbers
unless they're literally lying and the
polls are like
broken beyond repair i mean
can is that is that is that a strong
possibility is that this is what i was
thinking like
maybe what happened in 2016 was the
polls were slightly off
not because they they couldn't find
trump's base and they fixed and they
went to fix it
maybe their attempts to fix it resulted
in them going the other direction
but i mean i feel like that's wishful
thinking right oh what are you gonna say
well i was just gonna say that i mean
polling is a really really hard thing to
do accurately i mean any type of social
science
quantification is going to be difficult
right i mean because basically what
you're doing with these polls is you
have
small groups and you're hoping that
you're you're gonna be as representative
as possible but there's no way to do
that without any type of bias
at all so i think you know when we look
at polls
you they have a margin of error for a
reason and i think they're usually
pretty
i mean they're pretty optimistic with
the margins of error that they give so
that's the first thing and also the
second thing is i see a lot of national
polls and people always love to talk
about the national polls
the american president is not chosen by
direct democracy right
so it's a lot more useful to do what you
do and talk about these specific states
that might be
swing states and how they're performing
in those areas but when i see some about
like overall you know biden is up
nationally it's like well it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter if
everybody in california loves biden and
hates trump like he was never going to
get those votes anyway
there's a poll from democracy institute
and i think the sunday express in the uk
that has
trump actually up nationally has biden
at 45 trump at 46.
and and that's why i asked you you know
i say like you're canadian yeah it's
because i wonder if the reason
the difference between these polls in
the us versus you know the sunday
express
is like you've got a uk company they
don't know or care
for the most part about our biases i'm
sure they do a little bit
but they're probably like from the
outside looking in here's what we see
and then you have all these companies
and universities whatever in the us
and they're in the bubble they're in the
fray they can't see outside of it
well i mean some insight i want to do i
do want to give as a canadian is that
you guys are absolutely insane when it
comes to election security like you you
don't have any yep
like you don't and it's you have voter
id in canada of course
why not of course i cannot for the life
of me think of a country that doesn't
aside from america and uh how it's
controversial in america i have no idea
it's racist
of course we have voter id law oh my
like have you ever have you ever seen
that video with ami horowitz where he
goes and
yeah so so for those that aren't
familiar this this this this guy amy
horowitz goes to a bunch of berkeley
students and says is voter id racist
they'll say yes
he asks them why and they're like oh
because you know people in these
minority communities can't find the dmv
or they can't afford it or they don't
have license they have a license or they
don't have the internet
so then he literally goes to harlem and
talks to a bunch of black people and my
and then they're all just basically like
what i have id yeah of course we have
the internet of course we have ids but
my favorite interaction
was where he's talking to this like
middle-aged black dude and he goes do
you know where the dmv at
the do you know where the dmv is at and
he goes yeah it's right over there on
25th street
like as if he was giving him directions
like of course he knows where the dm's
how insanely racist are these people no
it's the bigotry of low expectations
for sure i think they're over white
supremacists yeah with guilty
consciences i mean they if you listen to
the stuff
the things that they say they
essentially want to treat black people
like pets
or mentally challenged children who
can't take care of themselves and you
know aren't able to self
to self-determine you know their futures
which is really really depressing
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you